is a rife machine the best way to kill cancer? I can't remember if I had this on last week or not.
I would say the rife machine doesn't kill cancer. Again, you have to be careful about any claims
that you're making. I think a rife machine properly programmed, properly working with the right
frequencies for that person that has cancer can help your immune system kill cancer. But I don't think
the rife machine directly destroys cancer or kills cancer. Even though I think anybody with cancer
should be using the rife machine, I don't think I'd be talking to you right now. I didn't
use the rife machine for my cancer. And I will stand by that, tell my death. I really think that's
besides the grace of God. I think God led me to be able to program rife for me and to get the benefits
from it. But I also say that it doesn't, it's not a magic wand. And it works at conjunction with
the person's immune system and other things that you're doing. So all those things together are the
best way to help deal with cancer. You've got to take a big picture view of everybody.
Because again, everybody is unique. So